let's now expose ourselves to another
test of convergence and that's the
alternating series test and i'll explain
the alternating series test and i'll
apply it to an actual series while i do
it to make the the
the explanation of the alternating
series test a little bit more concrete
so let's say
that i have some series
some infinite series let's say it goes
from n equals k
to infinity
of a sub n
and let's say i can write it as or i can
rewrite a sub n so let's say a sub n i
can write
so a sub n is equal to
negative 1 to the n
times b sub n
or
a sub n is equal to negative 1
to the n plus 1
times b sub n
where
where b sub n is greater than or equal
to 0 for all the n's we care about so
for all of these integer n's greater
than or equal to k
so if all of these things if all of
these things are true and we know two
more things
and we know
number one the limit
as n approaches infinity
of b sub n is equal to zero and
number two
b sub n
is a decreasing sequence
decreasing
decreasing sequence
then that lets us know
that the original infinite series
the original infinite series is going to
converge
so this might seem a little bit abstract
right now let's actually you show let's
let's use this with an actual series to
make it a little bit more a little bit
more concrete
so let's say that i had the series
let's say i had the series from n equals
1
to infinity of
negative 1
to the n
over
n
and we could write it out just to make
this series a little bit more concrete
when n is equal to 1 this is going to be
negative 1
to the 1 power actually let's just make
this a little bit let's make this a
little bit more interesting let's make
this negative 1 to the n plus 1. so when
n is equal to 1 this is going to be
negative 1 squared over 1 which is going
to be 1
and then when n is 2 it's going to be
negative 1 to the third power which is
going to be negative
one-half so it's minus one half
plus one third
minus one fourth plus minus and it just
keeps going on and on and on forever
now can we rewrite this a sub n like
this well sure the negative one to the n
plus 1 is actually explicitly called out
we can rewrite
we can rewrite our a sub n so let me do
that
so negative so a sub n which is equal to
negative 1
to the n plus 1
over n
this is clearly the same thing as
negative 1 to the n plus 1 times 1 over
n
which is
which we can then say
this thing right over here could be our
b sub n
so this right over here is our b sub n
and we can verify that our b sub n is
going to be greater than or equal to
zero for all the ends we care about so
our b sub n
is equal to one over n
now clearly this is going to be greater
than or equal to zero for any for any
positive n
now what's the limit as b sub n approach
what's the limit of b sub n as n
approaches infinity
the limit of let me just write 1 over n
1 over n
as n approaches infinity is going to be
equal to 0 so we satisfy the first
constraint
and then this is clearly a decreasing
sequence as n as n increases the
denominators are going to increase and
with a larger denominator you're going
to have a lower value
so we can also say 1 over n is a
decreasing
decreasing
sequence
for the ends that we care about so this
is this satisfies this is satisfied as
well and so based on that
this thing this thing is always
this thing right over here is always
greater than or equal to zero the limit
as one over n or is our b sub n
as n approaches infinity is going to be
zero it's a decreasing sequence
therefore we can say that our original
series actually converges
so n equals 1 to infinity of negative 1
to the n plus 1 over n and that's kind
of interesting because we've already
seen that if all of these were positive
if all of these terms were positive we
just have the harmonic series
and that one didn't converge but this
one did putting these negatives here do
the trick and actually we can prove this
one over here converges using other
techniques and maybe if we have time
actually in particular the limit
comparison test i'll just throw that out
there in case you are curious so this is
a pretty powerful tool it looks a little
bit about like that divergence test but
remember the divergence test is really
is only useful if you want to show
something diverges if the limit of if
the limit of your terms do not approach
zero then you say okay that thing is
going to diverge this thing is useful
because you can actually prove
convergence now once again if something
does not pass the alternating series
test that does not necessarily mean that
it diverges it just means that you
couldn't use the alternating series test
to prove that it converges